yes Kimberly the government has been
facing questions about whether it acted
too slowly to tackle this crisis so this
is where we are today you can see 596
deaths now we often see a lag on the
weekends the numbers can be slightly
lower but this is the lowest number we
have seen now for nearly two weeks and
if we look at how our figures compared
to other countries you can see we are
following in that similar trajectory to
countries like Italy and France now the
focus today has been on what Britain was
doing much earlier in the outbreak well
before lockdown at a time when it seemed
the virus was mainly a Chinese problem
so let's take this same chart back to
that first government Cobra meeting on
the 24th of January at this point China
had put Wuhan into lockdown 18 people
you can see that line there representing
the number of deaths in China 18 people
who died in the country on the same day
Europe reported its first cases in
France the UK would see its first
confirmed case a week later now Italy
locked down Lombardy on the 21st of
February a day later we would see the
first deaths there but by now the UK
government had set out that plan to
contain delay research and mitigate it
was nearly two weeks after that the
first person died in the UK and more
than a fortnight after that that we went
into lockdown here by then there were
three hundred and thirty five reported
hospital deaths and this is where we are
now it's more than 16,000 people have
died in hospital we've had time to
prepare we've seen the trajectory in
other countries but we're locking down
earlier have made a difference and there
isn't a simple right answer that says
you press this button and it will all go
away it's it's about managing the
competing of the deaths
you know tragic deaths on one hand with
the interventions on the other had we
got into this state of lockdown
mid-january yeah then then quite
possibly we would have had very very few
cases the government has always said its
decisions will be guided by the science
but some of those very scientists are
now warning that the threat of new
waves of the virus in the coming months
means it's too soon to say for sure
whether the right decisions were made at
the right time